hello and welcome to storage 202 getting
beyond data gravity moving your data to
cloud I'm one of your co-hosts ash
Ahluwalia I'm a product manager for the
Google cloud platform and I work on
transfer products that help you move
your data over the network thanks ash hi
folks I'm Abhishek Lal a product manager
with Google cloud platform I'm excited
to present the session today and discuss
moving your data to the cloud we will
start by discussing data transfer use
cases and challenges then move to some
exciting announcements that we have to
share we will also do a deep dive into
all the new capabilities and finally
conclude with Q&A at the end of the
session so to start let's talk a little
bit about why we built this suite of
transfer products and the principle
motivation is that being able to move
your data is an important prerequisite
to getting value out of your Google
Cloud investment across a variety of use
cases whether you're trying to lower
your costs by archiving or offloading
your storage to the cloud or in
situations where you're trying to get
more value from your data by running
analytical on machine learning pipelines
it also applies in situations where
you're lifting and shifting a workload
to cloud as part of a larger
transformation initiative and in some
instances it's important to be able to
move your data to share information
between organizations within your
company and with external partners and
customers when moving your data into the
cloud customers may face several
challenges scaling your processes and
scripts to terabytes and even petabytes
is laborious utilizing all of your
resources from so psyops network
bandwidth and then optimizing tools and
API calls requires a lot of tuning
validating data integrity across formats
and transfer errors can be tricky and
finally all the time that you spend in
building this knowledge and completing
the operations could be better spent on
something that has longer-term sustained
business value han
at google cloud we have several transfer
services to address these challenges
next Ashe will provide an overview of
what we offer let's talk a bit about the
transfer product offerings that we have
today and we'll start with the storage
transfer service which is a managed
service for large-scale batch data
transfers from one DCP region to another
or from other clouds like AWS s3 into
Google Cloud Storage the second product
offering the storage transfer service
for on-premises data helps you move data
from on-premises file systems into
Google Cloud storage that is also a
managed service for large-scale batch
data transfers in some instances you
need to move your data from your private
data center to cloud and it's just a
small bit of data and for that we offer
the GS util of command-line utility this
is a utility you can vote inside of a
script or from the shell as part of your
daily workflow now all the products that
I've talked about so far move data over
the network in some instances you have
too much data to move over the network
it would just take too long
or you may have no network connectivity
at all in those instances we can ship
you a physical product called the
transfer appliance which you can load
with data and then ship back to Google
for upload to the cloud so let's now
talk a little bit about the new product
announcements and updates that we've
made to these services we'll start with
the storage transfer service which moves
data between clouds we're really excited
today to announce that we're launching a
public global beta for supporting
Elizabeth lob storage this will enable
you to move data from Azure blob storage
to Google Cloud Storage which all with
all of the features that we offer for s3
to Google Cloud Storage transfers today
in addition we're announcing a public
beta for VP C service controls this will
enable you to move data from outside of
Google cloud into a Google cloud storage
bucket that is inside of a security
perimeter
in addition it'll enable you to move
data between two security perimeters if
the source bucket is in one perimeter
and the destination bucket is in another
will enable you to move data between the
two finally we've launched
number of improvements for programmatic
usage of the service starting with the
customer provided job IDs this will
enable you to set the transfer ID for
transfers you're executing so you don't
have to maintain mappings to other ID
spaces for instance if you're running
pipelines that do a lot of data
transfers you can just use your pipeline
run ID as your job ID and that'll make
troubleshooting and tracking a whole lot
easier
we're also enabling the ability to
choose objects from the source based on
their last modified time so you can also
for instance move all objects that will
last modified in January and finally
we're announcing the availability of
pub/sub notifications when a transfer
completes we will publish a message to a
pub sub topic that you have configured
in advance and you can then use that
message to trigger your downstream
actions for instance if you want to now
start processing the data that's been
transferred you can do so
programmatically with that pub sub
notification now let's talk about the
storage transfer service for on-premises
data this was announced as entering
public beta late lat last year in cloud
next London and we're really excited to
announce today that we are launching it
into public ta in addition we're at in
the abadan support for VP C service
controls in beta this will allow you to
move data from your on-premises file
system into Google Cloud Storage buckets
that are inside of a security perimeter
in addition this this will make the
service compatible with scenarios where
your security Primmer extends beyond
cloud and includes your on-premises of
filer resources now let me pass it on to
a Bechet to talk about updates for
transfer appliance Thank You ash I'm
excited to announce a new SKU of the
transfer of clients currently we have ta
100 and ta 480 as the two models
available in coming months we will roll
out the TA 300 next let's understand
each of these new features and
capabilities in details so let's start
by doing a quick walk through a virtual
demo if you will of the storage transfer
service moving data from Azure blob
storage to Google Cloud Storage bucket
now before we do that let's just talk a
little bit more about this what this
service is designed
so firstly it's designed to be fast it
uses Google infrastructure underneath so
you're using for instance Google's
provision network pipes from Google Data
Centers to AWS and is where data centers
in addition it's designed to scale to
petabytes of data and then finally we
will allocate a number of workers behind
the scenes to paralyze your data
transfer and you don't have to deal with
any of that that's all happening
seamlessly behind the scenes without any
management or intervention from you
secondly it's designed to be easy the
interface is very simple and you choose
your source bucket and credentials your
destination bucket and schedule and then
hit go and it starts moving your data
and when we talk through a more detailed
example in just a little bit it's also
supports moving data from a blob storage
s3 and you can also give it a list of
HTTP URLs so any any data you can reach
with a browser you can move with this
product and finally it's compatible with
all GCP supported languages so it should
be easy to integrate within your current
architecture and then finally this
service is designed to be secured all
connections are encrypted with TLS
encryption
it supports I am so you can control
which users can transfer data which
users can edit transfers and then also
supports data integrity by doing check
sums of objects at the source and
destination to make sure no bytes have
been corrupted in fight and finally as
we just announced it supports BBC
service controls now in beta so let's
walk through a more detailed example in
demo so if you're going to start by you
know to move data from a server
blobstore did you see yes there's some
initial setup you need to do for the
product as with many Google cloud
platform products you need to give
yourself your client application access
to the storage transfer service API and
in addition you need to give the storage
transfer service service account which
moves data on your behalf access to your
source and destination now once you do
that
let's just talk through you know how
does a transfer actually work with the
service well there are two kind of key
concepts to understand the first is the
job the job essentialy capsule eats the
configuration for what you want to do in
the transfer the source destination
credentials schedules and transfer
options and that sort of thing and then
the second concept that's important
understand is the Opera
the operation captures it captures a
specific instance or execution of a
transfer so for instance you may
configure a job to run every day at noon
and you will have an operation for
Tuesday's run at noon which will tell
you specifically what happened on that
transfer with counters and errors and
that's worth it
so is submitting a job is essentially
just a two-step process you submit a
config the config will tell you when
this transfer should be scheduled to run
and then the service on its own when the
schedule fires will create a transfer
operation and execute the transfer as
you've configured it so let's take a
look at that in a little bit more detail
here's an example we have of how you
might use our rest interface to submit a
new transfer job now let's just zoom
into pieces of this so we can understand
what information you're sending a lot
we'll start with information about the
source and destination so as you can see
here you would supply information about
yours or blob storage account container
and your credentials so we can access
your source data in addition you would
supply information about the destination
GCS bucket where you want your Gator to
go another part of the proto is
schedules so you can schedule they're
comprised of three parts first when does
the schedule start when does it end and
at what time do we execute all transfer
all storage transfer service jobs run
daily so in this example ours is equal
to one and minutes is equal to one which
means this job of one at 101 a.m. and
then finally you can also submit a
number of transfer options which will
help you control whether you're allowed
to overwrite data for objects that
already exist at the destination or if
you want for instance to delete data
after it's been copied so more of a move
operation instead of creating a second
copy and then you can also submit
information about what source objects
you want us to select for instance you
can choose objects based on the last
modified time or you can use including
our next food prefixes to choose objects
based on their name so for example you
can choose an include prefix of food
slash and that would mean that we pull
all objects that start with whose prefix
starts with food slash so after you
submit a job you're gonna get a response
and as you can see from this pretty
response here most of that response is
the config that you provided played back
to you
but there's some of that response that I
think is informed to highlight so let's
zoom in on that now if we take a look at
that there are some standard Manor data
you might expect we can tell you when
the job configuration resource was
created but we also include the job name
this is a unique identifier at the
project level that you can use to make
subsequent calls if you want to for
instance figure out whether the job is
still running what operations have been
executed as part of the job so if for
instance you want to monitor a transfer
let's just look at that example in a
little bit more detail and so this is
again you know showing you the request
that you're making and the full response
now let's just zoom into pieces of it so
we can understand it a bit better so
first starting with the request as I
mentioned before you submit the project
ID and then the this unique job name
which will help us identify the job
resource and respond and the response
will contain the list of operations that
have been executed or are executing as
part of this job configuration now if
you look at aspects of the response it's
an array of operations and each
operation will contain some important
information it'll contain when this
operation when this execution began when
it completed and what status it
completed with was it a success or a
failure it'll also include error
information that you might use for
detail troubleshooting and it will also
include some counters that'll help you
understand how much data actually made
it in both byte and countenance so let's
look through those counters in a little
bit more detail so in both byte encount
units we're showing you essentially
every aspect of what the service did how
many objects did we find
how many obviously we take action on
whether we were copying them or
completing them at the source or
destination and then finally how many
objects or bytes did we fail to act on
so you can use this for some of your
more detailed monitoring so that was an
example of how we moved data from less
of a blob storage to Google Cloud
Storage now let's talk about the storage
transfer service for on-premises data
which helps to move data from private
data centers to Google cloud so an
overview of this service it is designed
again to be fast this service requires
you to install a piece of software
we're which we call the agent to help us
push data to Google Cloud and we've
worked a lot to make that process
seamless all you need to do is cut and
paste a few commands and your agent
installed and ready to go it's also
designed to scale to petabytes of data
and multiple tens of VP bits per second
so it is very appropriate to use for
large data transfers and then finally
making the service the service is
designed to be scalable so if you want
the service to run faster all you need
to do is bring up more agents and we
will push more data in parallel and you
should be able to get better speeds
secondly it's designed to be easy we try
to make the management and operation of
this product as simple and easy as
possible for you so for instance the
agent software auto updates you don't
have to worry about that it works just
like you know chrome auto updates do
today it also works on all connection
types that at Google supports so whether
using the public interconnect public
internet a direct interconnect or
partner and connect as long as you can
connect to the cloud on this date this
product should be able to move data for
you and finally it's designed to be
secure it uses TLS encryption to protect
your data while it's in flight and also
computes checksums at the source and
destination to make sure that no bytes
have been corrupted while the transfer
is occurring and finally as we mentioned
before it also now supports in public
beta security perimeters so let's talk a
little bit more about what the journey
looks like when you're trying to use
this product so as I mentioned before
you have to the first step to set it up
is to download and install our agent
software this software sits inside of a
dr container image so in that container
which actually contains more than just
the binary for the agent it also
contains this auto updating component
that we talked about earlier and a
process monitor so if the agent process
dies within the container we can bounce
it back up without you having to worry
about it or include that in your
operations and the other thing I'll just
mention is because this is inside of a
docker container we encourage you to use
that with whatever orchestration
mechanism you have for instance if you
use kubernetes to run many ages that'll
help us paralyze or transfer and get you
faster speeds once you've done this
one-time setup then running a transfer
is as simple as going into the
Google Cloud console the GUI for the
Google cloud platform
and submitting a source directory in the
destination bucket and once you do that
the agents will all start working in
parallel to move your data across and
you can monitor what's happening with
your transfer right there in the GUI you
can see what errors have been recorded
and all the counters that we talked
about earlier in addition one thing I'd
like to highlight is that this agent
fabric is fault tolerance so if let's
say you're running ten agents and five
of them go down the transpose will still
keep running and it might run a little
bit slower because fewer agents are
running but the transfer will still make
progress if all of the agents go down
that's okay too
the transfer won't make progress because
there are no agents available to push
data but as soon as agents come back up
all of your pending transfers will pick
up where they left off so you don't have
to implement any sort of special
recovery or retry logic the service has
all of that built in with that let me
pass it over to of a sheikh to talk a
little bit more about the new transfer
appliance product that we announced
today thank you so much ash I'm excited
to introduce the Google transfer
appliance ta 300 we are always listening
to our users to understand their
evolving needs and this new appliance
addresses several of the features and
requirements you have asked for next let
me highlight these asks from customers
when migrating workloads customers want
to minimize the downtime and thus reduce
impact to their users fast transfers
reduce the disruptions to rhythms of
business when moving applications to the
cloud moving large data volumes can
sometimes be disruptive to already
stretched network bandwidth and the cost
considerations could make it
unattractive to go and procure new
circuits
finally there are remote and mobile
situations like ships when you need to
collect data locally and in a secure and
efficient manner
once you dock at the port you want to
then move this data quickly to the cloud
earnings from these users have helped
guide the design of the next generation
of transfer appliances the new transfer
appliance ta 300 delivers a simple
secure and performant way to move your
data into Google cloud platform this is
targeted at customers who are unable to
move data online due to limited
bandwidth a desire to reduce the cost
incurred on network provisioning or do
not have the network connectivity
available in remote and mobile scenarios
next let's look at the user experience
for transferring your data with the TA
300 customers start by submitting an
order form in the Google Cloud console
we validate your source location needs
and ship out the appropriate appliance
for your requirements when you receive
the appliance inspected for any signs of
damage or tampering a simple attestation
program is used to validate that none of
the hardware or software within the
appliance was tampered in transit now
the appliance is ready for you to use
simply connected to your network mount
the NFS share exposed and copy your data
once all this copying is completed you
can seal the appliance this finalization
step protects the appliance and your
data from tampering during transit and
it is required before shipping back your
appliance
when returned to our processing facility
we attest the integrity of the appliance
and move your data securely into the
destination bucket we then inform you of
the successful completion of the
transfer as simple as that next let's
see the individual capabilities in
detail
the appliance is ready to use when it
applies you remove it from the case
place it on a desk or a rack shelf and
connect the power all the cables you
need are included in the case the server
itself is designed for performance and
reliability all SSD drives give you
faster writes networking can scale up to
40 Gbps and data integrity is maintained
across all the system layers this is a
cost-effective service with a simple
usage fee model you can scale up the
capacity of transfers by ordering
multiple appliances in parallel this can
help you maximize the usage of your
source data systems the internet speed
as well as optimize the end-to-end
transfer time next let's see how easy it
is to move your data to the cloud with
the appliance you do not need any
proprietary software to move data into
this server just mount the NFS share
from your workstation and use any copy
and copy tools like robocopy
or sync to move your files a single NFS
share is exposed with the entire
capacity making it easy for you to run
many copy processes in parallel the
local command line interface lets you
initialize the server configure IP ports
and check the status of the appliance
the data on the server is always
encrypted and we help you all along the
way with shipping logistics and any
required support we are looking to make
the new ta 300 available in all our main
regions starting with the US then EU and
followed by a PAC in coming quarters
next let's tour the security features
built into the TA 300 customers care
deeply about the security of their data
and we take this shared responsibility
seriously starting with tamper-evident
tags on the transfer appliance
case to the TPM chip used to validate
the internals every step has been
designed and tested for security the
remote attestation process validates
several aspects of the appliance after
it has been in transit
first the TPM module is validated then
the platform configuration registers are
used to check the immutable root
filesystem and software components such
as the bootloader os Google binaries and
customer managed public key materials
this is done both at the customer site
when they receive the appliance and at
Google processing centers when the
appliances are returned our processes
are built for supporting all the key
compliance standard and audited
regularly we are there to support you in
all the steps including wiping the
appliance and issuing a NIST 8:08
certificate for that operation we are
looking forward to serving your needs
with the new offer next some important
additional resources and information
thanks so much ash for the session today
and I wanted to thank everyone who
joined our session today I hope you
enjoy our discussion on the use cases
challenges and solution that Google
offers to enable you to move your data
to cloud and we hope you will try out
all the exciting new capabilities that
we have announced today thank you so
much and really appreciate your time